[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
i got that elon musk trouble weed
what is that first of the car [ __ ] it
dropped tesla stock six percent in one
day oh my uh my manager and pr person
out there are just literally [ __ ]
their pants right now
but it's legal well it's legal here
right now
there you go
i believe in the law
it's 100 legal here
it is 100
who's the dude that uh
oh mike tyson just brought you some of
his weed
is that how it comes this is the box of
death and life right here wow mike
tyson's box of death and life yeah look
at th this is how hard mike tyson rolls
look at the size of these [ __ ] joints
he gave me
i know the camera's not gonna be able to
follow me but i'll be right back ladies
and gentlemen
look at this [ __ ]
look at the [ __ ]
size
oh that's just insane that's dude that's
you bro i can't take that i can't take
it with you
how do i get on the plane then you just
think think and you'll appear in the
seat 4c i don't even know what [ __ ]
planet you're on right there but i
barely do ah
how are you going to [ __ ] make this
happen for this this is the highest
you've ever been already it's it's that
thing i haven't taken any edibles in a
while four things it's four times my
normal dose
because
25 times your normal dose it doesn't
listen that it's way way past what i
would ever take to get super high
i get on a plane or i want to zonk out
50 milligrams
the girls at the dispensaries
they think you're weird well
maybe i'm just paranoid but i come in
and i buy like a pack of 600 like three
times a week
what do you do with these me and the
[ __ ] security guard on our first name
basis yeah shut up daddy what's up betty
yeah he wanted to clean
still messed up and i know why man hey
wow this is great this is a we're doing
the chris and eddie show woo
and salvo kano is my guess my bff for
life i took an edible five millis i'm
[ __ ] smacked a million million
million million million like i used to
smoke weed like i'm sober unfortunately
right it [ __ ] sucks but for now it
sucks but um i got so high in college
one time um that i called the cops on
myself right and people have done this
right it's pretty normal
um this is popular for i don't know if
it happens to everybody it definitely
happens to white people where like you
get high and call the cops but there was
a party at our place so everybody's
outside [ __ ] partying so i the
ambulance is coming right so here's what
i did bro i waited till they were coming
in the front and then i came out the
back door and went and got in the
ambulance and the shotgun right oh my
god and just waited until they came back
out of the party because i don't want to
be embarrassed like being carried out on
a stretch or anything you know that's
crazy i was still like so self-conscious
so i was just sitting in the ambulance
by myself even though i called it and
they come back and get back in and
they're like uh hello and i was like
yeah i'm the guy that called let's get
the [ __ ] out of here let's go going
we're feeling all right yeah i'm just
going to get some man yeah now
i'm i'm [ __ ] crazy high though okay
you want me to you want more more water
yeah okay let's do some water yeah [ __ ]
i told you you want to leave too i saved
you because i like man one of the few
guys in comedy i'd behave around
you and steve burton i like his both
you're gentlemen and [ __ ] that's why i
wanted to have you on the show every
time i see owen benjamin i always behave
myself as a comic i don't say a [ __ ]
word because he's such a nice guy really
thanks you and steve burns all right so
it's 20 minutes after the hour so
let's get smoking
yeah
so just pick up anything you want but i
was going to suggest the honey farm
vapor pen for you okay because it's real
tasty it doesn't really taste like
marijuana but it does get you high and
as long as you don't take too big of a
rip off of it i think it'll be a good
base
high for you to get started which ones
are the sativas uh all of them indica's
uh in this right here if you want indica
just loaded up special cool but uh just
uh grab a lighter and uh hit anything
you want and that one we gotta load up
too but we can load it and just take a
second just hit one of these other ones
in the meantime
[Laughter]
pretty tasty though right
yeah good stuff
you know i ate six dogs
how can you handle six times because
we're in training on benjamin you
understand me i'll give you a bag to go
and then you'll be in training and
you'll be a soldier of the church
people will see it and now when they see
it they'll bring you something for your
baby and the best edible that city has
to make
and they're going to say we heard you on
the church here you go you're in
training nice i'm trying harder
mushrooms
yeah they'll bring you acid mushrooms
all the fun stuff that you could take in
the hotel room by yourself right
it's just my [ __ ] mind sure wouldn't
like pod yeah
throw on some pink floyd just [ __ ]
that's it it's over we don't do that
much [ __ ] no more like that we don't go
back to the room and put music on and
sit there and meditate there's two diaz
stories that he completely to the point
where all right so i went and did a gig
with him
where like we get on the plane right
before we get on the plane
we're at burbank airport in l.a is so
lax which is the massive one of the
busiest airports in the world and then
burbank has like 12 gates right it's a
tiny airport
and so he's like meet me at burbank
airport right so
flights are booked and then
diaz we walk through there he gives me
he's like eat this i just eat this
you don't even ask questions
yeah and then he's like i run this
airport tom
who says that right like i run this
airport so silly and then we're walking
through and he's like
like a pilot walks by and goes like hey
joey i'm like
and then like it hits it hits me how
high i am
and then uh
diaz like
we're walking towards the gate and he
goes hey tsa this tsa agent i'm like
what are you about to do right now like
why would you draw attention right and
he points to me he's like check him out
and i was like oh what i just like a
beeline i just walk away from him yeah
and i walk into like a magazine store
and i look back and he and the ts agent
are like giving like hugging each other
and he's like talking to him i'm like i
don't even know
right now
and so i just i grab a magazine
i buy a magazine and i go and i go what
was that he's like what was what i go
why are you talking to tsa he's like
dude i told you i know everybody here
all right i'm just going to ignore this
then i'm sitting there waiting to board
my flight and i realized that the
magazine
that i bought i left there like i left
so far but it's really started like my
face is melting you know so like so so i
walk back and it's sitting there on the
counter but it's a different person than
i bought it from
so i just point to it and i'm so out of
my mind i go that's mine
like a child
okay
and i bought it already
okay
take it and walk away
did i just get away with
my magazine and here's keep this in mind
i eat like a 10 milligram thing i'm just
like out of my mind right
he eats it eats another one eats a third
one has a four like just starts popping
them like it's just tic tacs
out of here eating him eating him eating
him we get on the plane i'm like oh you
know just spaced out like oh i don't
know where i am it's a little panicking
and as we start to land on this flight i
start to chill out
and then i go ah man so glad that like
it's starting to wear off man i was i
was kind of like getting nervous there
like it's crazy that you don't feel that
way what are you talking about i almost
had three panic attacks
yeah i'm freaking out right now
and then you get up and he's like you
want to smoke a joint i'm like no
i want it to be over
he likes to live there you took the
hundred milligram on the flight back i
fly back i started freaking out that the
plane was gonna go down
and then they pulled the plane over to
the side because of the rain in the
midwest and they kept saying if we don't
leave in 30 seconds and 30 minutes we're
probably gonna have to cancel a flight
until tomorrow morning i'm high as a
[ __ ] and i'm thinking maybe i took the
wrong plane i switched
and maybe because i was supposed to
leave sadly you're out of your mind at
this point out of my mind i'm an hour in
with earphones the plane was at the gate
for half hour and they made the edible
go up and then we drove around all over
[ __ ] new york city with kennedy
airport we were cutting off ubers i'm
like where the [ __ ] is this plane going
and i saw a little arabs pulled over to
the side [ __ ] you
i'm trying to drive uberx
the purple is a satives and you're gonna
want to do that to be chats purple
sativa so sativa's the one that's a
little bit more energy yes okay so i'm
gonna take about take a five milligrams
to tevia stevia yes
take it and then you you're gonna take
it yeah i'll take one sure you take one
chris and eddie show's gonna start about
15 minutes i'm gonna let it kick in all
right what is babe are these are like uh
how delicious were they amazing are they
under the denver denver oh this is all
in the oven right and what was the dose
it was five oh okay but to be honest
with you i'm gonna smoke a little as
well okay good good you know what
because i want to give you guys an
experience so am i
after six months of getting in his ear
about smoking weed i was like trying to
convince him to smoke weed i'm like so
funny he's so funny without weed i go if
i could get him to smoke weed because
everything everybody thought i was crazy
for smoking weed so back in back in the
day
and then i finally convinced him we were
in his nsx he pulls over and he goes
okay [ __ ] pull it out i'm like not
right now i had a man bag
but it was while we were driving it took
six months
he pulls over and goes pull it out
that's the [ __ ] right now get it pulled
out this is going to be a cartoon for
sure
there he goes
i'm like i told him i like i didn't
drive for six months when i started
smoking weed i wouldn't drive i was too
scared he goes dude let's just do it i'm
like yeah i'm like listen [ __ ] i got
brain damage gangster
and i go [ __ ] we gotta go to [ __ ]
baskin robbins he's got to feel that
[ __ ] because this is it i finally
convinced them to do it so let's go to
is there an ice cream place there's a
baskin robbins down on tapanga i go
let's [ __ ] we made up as high as you can
you know that first time and you never
knew you never snapped after that that
was that was it that was it and then
check this out every day well i take
october
no no no he doesn't remember but there
was some up in ups and downs but that's
why i remember that night that night we
went to baskin robbins he had a [ __ ]
hot fudge sundae and we went to the
comedy store and he got on stage the
first night he smoked weed and this joke
i'll never afraid he goes dude i got
high for the first time today
and damn i didn't realize hot fudge
sundaes were so [ __ ] good
january like my special comes out
january 17th [ __ ] gets crazy joe's like
yo can we do the podcast like
24th right now the the pandemic is in it
is kicked in no one's leaving their
house no one's on the 405. no one's on
the 101. i make it to joe's podcast
studio in like seven minutes right i'm
there early joe's there early where he
you know what's crazy is he doesn't give
me a hug you know whenever you see joe
he gives you that wraps you up in that
big hug yeah he doesn't give me a hug
just stands off like he's mad at you
right and you're like oh [ __ ] and then
he goes
he's like you know how you feeling how
are you doing i said good i haven't left
the house like cool we go in he's like
you want i can use a cocktail and i was
like me too and then he gives me
my own joint right so i get my own joint
he's got his own joint
start smoking and then all of a sudden i
start getting paranoid i'm like i'm like
get a little shortness of breath like oh
[ __ ] i got the covered my throats i can
feel my throat really intensely and i'm
like i gotta get that i gotta [ __ ] i
just ended up murdering alcohol to get
rid of the coven
sure madness yeah those things are
strong going
yeah he's just relaxing this is the
devil here tonight
this is it this is as good as it gets
people it's a [ __ ] monday night i'm
the church of what's happening now
where's tony bennett did you even line
it up and i know you didn't see you're
[ __ ] slipping lisayette
thank god owen benjamin's on the show
tonight let's smoke this [ __ ] bowl
while lisa does this thing you want to
take ahead of this old benjamin this
will get the blood pressure down
another hit i don't want to see
something
i can really [ __ ] function oh yeah
i want to be around this is it baby
where's the [ __ ] life
i had 10 lives
you guys get this hat is like weird
they're calling you a new soldier in
training that's right you're you've got
like eight stars you're when they start
doing that yeah [ __ ] yeah
that's it
you're the man of steel
what's the [ __ ] what happened to tony
bennett that was quick i turned him off
because you're coming back no i'm just i
just went to open the door to give my
main man to mayor
because i've been where he's
been i mean
that guy didn't pop the second one he
wanted to eat another one i go no no no
just see how this one tastes good
you know i know you live down the beach
i see you out of the night smoking
i figured you could handle it relax for
a little while you ain't driving you
can't drive right the car you gotta go
all the way to the 90s
[Music]
i got a probiotic in here i got some
green juice
oh yeah you're all right is it for a
while sure
ryan sickler and i were in the parking
lot before i'm jealous oh and ryan's
always got good weed yeah he had
some crazy sticky [ __ ] and
and he was like
uh you wanna he's like you wanna smoke i
didn't i thought norm was gonna be like
i'm about to go on stage which he was
and he was like yeah i was like you're
gonna smoke right but i was like you're
gonna smoke right now because that was
like
so scary to me to get that high right
before
he packed this bowl norm hit it took a
monster
i watched him take a monster off of
cough rogan one time so hard tear came
down his face you know like when you're
coughing that hard and i was like this
is gonna be
bad you know
i took a hit cause i was watching him we
weren't we weren't performing that night
and um
the show's already started and i had
that like you know that anxiety yeah
like of like a five-year comic and he's
a 30-year guy at the time yeah like
don't you gotta get in there he's like
huh
i guess all i can think about is like
you gotta get in there man
i took 20 milligrams on my last flight
to new york and that was too [ __ ]
much for me really 20 milligrams would
do something new
first do something i took 50 on the
flight there no man [ __ ] up i was
[ __ ] up dude these are soldiers lisa i
had dog you ain't got time to [ __ ]
around with uncle joe the problem with
the red ones though is i have to eat
five of them to even feel anything
how much are the rare ones
you see five of those
feel anything well we're feeling we're
ready to get a little high no i i know i
gotta yeah i get the feeling i get that
i got that but at 6 25 is you're like
yeah i mean let's do it if we're gonna
do it that's what that is
now
after four years of
yeah constant marijuana
[Laughter]
it's not like it's only a documentary
either it's like you just want to do it
yeah
you're like i'll keep them around and
see what happens
i've been to it though yeah you've been
to a thousand you've crossed the four
digits yeah damn
wow
pretty soon when i eat that whole five
thousand milligrams
it's one show you ever hear stuff that's
not around apparently monster on the
show but not before that
[Music]
you